sur le front
ukrainien à présent une nouvelle réunion
des alliés de qui avait organisé
aujourd'hui pour coordonner à l'aide
militaire et union prévue sur la base
américaine de Rammstein en Allemagne en
présence du secrétaire américain à la
Défense et du patron de l'otanienne
soultonberg tout juste rentré de Kiev on
en parle avec vous Armel charrier
bonjour à vous Armel vlodimers qui
continue de mettre la pression sur
l'Alliance atlantique pour obtenir plus
d'armes et pour que son pays adhère à
l'OTAN Kiev qui dit préparer une
contre-offensive d'ampleur et pour cela
il a donc besoin d'aide le président
ukrainien on l'a vu à des attentes
concrètes principalement en termes de
défense entière qu'en est-il c'est
crucial pour lui parce qu'on a les
attaques de drones on a les attaques de
missiles qui viennent de la Russie qui
d'ailleurs suit parfaitement quelles
sont les dispositifs dont bénéficient
maintenant l'Ukraine avec tout ce qui
est solaire et qui essaie de les
contourner avec des missiles par exemple
ultra rapide mais clairement là pour
l'instant l'Ukraine a reçu les patriotes
qui étaient tout ce qui était promis par
les Américains par les Pays-Bas par la
Pologne aussi elle a reçu évidemment des
crottes qui venaient de la France on a
doit fournir des mambas avec la France
et l'Italie et il doit y avoir aussi des
asams qui sont des systèmes
anti-missiles qui est moitié norvégien
moitié américain très performant donc ça
c'est pour j'allais dire ce chapitre là
l'autre chose que demande Céline ski
évidemment pour avoir la maîtrise du
ciel c'est d'avoir des avions et ça ce
qu'on a bien retenu c'est que pour
l'instant les Américains le refusent en
disant qu'ils ont trop peur qu'ils
étaient à cobelligérance et donc les
seuls avions qui ont été fournis ce sont
par des pays qui sont proches en fait de
l'Ukraine la Slovaquie la Bulgarie en
ont déjà fourni la Pologne et ça c'est
davantage des avions de type de l'air
soviétique donc que les
Ukrainiens facilement utiliser et la
Macédoine a même rajouté aussi des
hélicoptères les livraisons de chats ont
aussi débuté il y a quelques semaines
ils sont essentiels pour pouvoir mener
cette contre-offensive donc par le ski
ou en sommes-nous de ces livraisons à ce
jour alors livraison de chats à partir
du moment donné vous avez une opération
terrestre c'est la cavalerie lourde donc
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
est fondamental à condition bien sûr
d'être dans une météo qui le permet le
char étant lourd étant avec des
chenilles si vous avez de la boue il
s'embourbe et donc du coup ça ne
fonctionne pas donc il faut attendre que
du coup tout ce qui est les pluies de
printemps soient passés les chars ce
qu'on a vu arriver les Britanniques
avaient tout de suite dit qu'ils
allaient fournir effectivement des chars
avec le charalais c'était les challenger
et les Britanniques ont déjà formé les
équipages en fait en Angleterre en
Pologne et donc ils ont déjà une
capacité d'être sur le terrain vous avez
les Abraham qui sont là encore
déterminants sont les Américains qui
l'ont annoncé avec une ancienne version
parce qu'ils se sont rendus compte que
s'ils mettaient la version la plus
nouvelle des délais étaient trop
importants et puis ensuite vous avez
différents types de pays qui ont fourni
le départ 2 qui est le char allemand
qu'on a par la Pologne qu'on a parlé le
Danemark et puis vous avez aussi la
France qui a fourni par exemple la mxrc
c'est un blindé que l'on a déjà vu sur
le sur le terrain donc ça c'est
effectivement une qualité pour les
Ukrainiens la difficulté qui rencontre
c'est que vous avez entendu tout le
nombre de chars que je vous ai cités ça
veut dire en fait que vous avez pas seul
type d'armement c'est donc difficile
forcément derrière pour l'entretien pour
les réparations et surtout si ça doit se
faire en dehors de l'Ukraine et que ça
doit repartir vers la Pologne pour
ensuite revenir ça ce serait une
faiblesse pour les Ukrainiens Armel
charrier merci à vous pour ce décryptage
et